ja das geräusch was mittlerweile auch
viele viertel nach acht zuschauer kennen
nämlich die sirene die ist heute sehr
sehr häufig wieder losgegangen zuletzt
ungefähr vor 10 minuten und wir haben
hier in der nähe des zentrums ebenfalls
mehrere explosionen gehört jetzt muss
man abwarten aber um ein gefühl zu
vermitteln kann ich sagen jeder in kiew
fragt sich an so einem vorhaben bevor
man schlafen geht wird ist heute nacht
die gefährlichste nach wird es heute den
großen angriff geben und allein das ist
ein wahnsinniger psychoterror wir auf
den menschen lastet die noch hier sind
ich war heute am bahnhof habe dort
rührende szenen erlebt frauen die sich
verabschiedet haben von ihren männern
die hier bleiben und kämpfen junge
frauen die ihre hunde und haustiere
mitnehmen nur aus in den westen nach
lemberg und dann habe ich petro
poroschenko getroffen den ehemaligen
präsidenten der ukraine nachdem ich
gestern den präsidenten seelands
getroffen hat und obwohl beide
erbitterte konkurrenten sind haben sie
etwas gemeinsam sie glauben dass der
westen putin immer noch unterschätzt
dass der westen immer noch nicht
verstanden hat wie gefährlich es wird
wenn putin in der ukraine erfolgreich
ist peter schwenkow sagt putin ist ein
killer und terrorist er fordert die
flugverbotszone genauso wie sie lenski
und genauso wie lenz gesagt der wenn
putin hier nicht aufgehalten wird dann
geht er weiter dann kommen die
baltischen staaten run oder wie sie
lenski gestern sagte dann geht er bis
ost berlin bei der ist ja die große
angst ich viele menschen hier in
deutschland haben mich inklusive die man
jeden tag spürt wo geht er hin wie weit
wird putin noch gehen und hier meine
frage an dich mit der bitte um
einschätzung was ist denn
wahrscheinlicher wird er nach georgien
gehen oder doch wenn er dann weitergehen
sollte ein nato gebiet angreifen
er ist momentan natürlich viel zu
beschäftigt mit der ukraine als dass er
einen weiteren krieg anfangen würde
militärisch läuft es nicht so wie er es
vielleicht gehofft hat aber auch da
gehen die analysen auseinander manche
sagen vielleicht nutzt er diese taktik
einfach um diesen ja diese angst diese
psycho angst auf das land zu legen und
danach aber wenn die ukraine so
vernichtet sein sollte wie er sagt
nämlich sagt die ukraine existiert gar
nicht sie gehört zu russland dann traue
ich ihm alles zu natürlich ist ein nato
staat und auch die nato wird sich jetzt
weiter warten eine größere hürde aber
wladimir putin und das sagen alle
beobachter ist nicht mehr
zurechnungsfähig und das macht ihn so
gefährlich
werde es der die gefahr besteht ja wie
sie paul beschreibt ganz real und die
psychologie die dahinter steckt ist ja
das eigentlich beklemmende also wenn ich
alles richtig sehe ist im moment eine
situation angerichtet das land die mir
putin machen kann was er will wenn er
deutschland bombardieren will
bombardiert der deutschland dann können
wir schauen wie wir uns da verteidigen
und was unsere antwort ist wenn er in
anderen ländern einmarschieren will die
er sich noch einverleiben will in seine
großmacht fantasien dann tut er das
diesen proof of concept diese
bestätigung dass der westen dann erst
mal diskutiert und natürlich in der
ständigen sorge die reaktion des westens
löst dann den dritten weltkrieg oder
zumindest eine große eskalation aus dass
genau dass das szenario ist das schmerzt
einem ja schon wenn man es ausspricht
weil man irgendwie so machtlos wird
gegen jemand der sich nimmt was er will
und der ist hinterlegt mit der drohung
wenn ihr das nicht zu lasten noch viel
schlimmeres an das ist die grosse ist
der große sachverhalt mit dem es sich
jetzt auseinander zu setzen und das ist
nicht trivial und ich glaube auch dass
alle führer des westens sozusagen
gänsehaut haben wenn sie darüber
nachdenken weil putin ja auch geschafft
hat das quasi die eskalation im westen
zukommt als sie die situation ist
psychologischer jetzt so angerichtet
dass wenn der westen reagiert gibt es
eben die eskalation
ich will aber ein kleines
hoffnungszeichen dahinter machen oder
auch nicht denn bloody mary putin sieht
er jetzt auch dass seine armee
vielleicht nicht ganz so stark ist wie
er selber und auch der westen gedacht
hat dass der soldaten hat die ihre
panzer im stich lassen nun zurück nach
russland laufen das im schlamm stecken
bleibt dass er viel stärker ist als die
ukraine das hat auch gelernt aber dass
er möglicherweise nicht stark genug ist
die auseinandersetzung die militärische
auseinandersetzung mit dem westlichen
bündnis aufzunehmen das kommt ihm auch
in den sinn und jetzt kommt aber der
entscheidende punkt es ist bei einem wie
ihm wahrscheinlich sogar egal dass er
begreift das ist eine große gefahr ist
er provoziert sie zu seinem vorteil und
im moment wenn man ein fazit zieht liegt
davon in der auseinandersetzung er ist
in der ukraine
er hat den psychologischen punkt auf
seiner seite wie eben beschrieben und
der westen weiß nicht so recht was er
machen soll als in seiner agenda
voranzuschreiten die aber endlich ist
herr zehn jahre liegt putin vorerst mal
vielen dank dass sich die zeit nehmen
dass sie sich heute zugeschaltet haben
aus ihrem wahlkreis vielen herzlichen
dank liegt putin vorne also hat herr
strunz recht dass putin aktuell vorne
liegt
ja militärisch hat er vieles in der hand
in der ukraine weil er über starke
streitkräfte verfügt aber ich sehe nicht
dass putin vorne liegt denn er hat sich
selbst in eine ziemlich ausweglose
situation politisch gebracht er hatte
russland international isoliert die
sanktionen greifen jetzt es gibt
diskussionen ob sie noch härter sein
könnten und müssten
ich glaube auch dass wir darüber
sprechen müssen was man noch mehr tun
kann aber diese sanktionen die es jetzt
schon gibt treffen putin hart und er
muss jetzt überlegen wie kommt er aus
dieser situation heraus und in einem
punkt würde ich am schluss wieder
sprechen das ist die frage wie reagiert
der westen wie reagiert die jugend vor
allem die nato wenn er weiter gehen
würde gegenüber einem nato staat da sind
die aussagen glasklar dass auch das
szenario general der es aber auch aller
regierungen östlich von uns jeder
quadratzentimeter von nato territorium
wird verteidigt und wird einen
sofortigen rückschlag der gesamten nato
nach sich ziehen das weiß putin es ist
für ihn ein gefährliches spiel deswegen
muss man unterscheiden zwischen der
situation in der ukraine und was würde
passieren wenn es zu einem vorfall käme
auf nato gebiet aber der punkt ist ja er
entscheidet dass das muss ja jeden der
gewohnt ist entscheidungen zu treffen
und sie max kennen sie ja aus ihrem cdu
auch das ist doch das was ein so
ohnmächtig erscheinen lässt er bestimmt
die agenda er tut etwas und wir
reagieren vielleicht angemessen
vielleicht nicht angemessen aber wir
reagieren aber er hat sozusagen die hand
am abzug und das ist das was den
menschen glaube ich angst macht weil es
sich bei ihm ihr offenbar um jemanden
handelt der zum allerschlimmsten
imstande ist er ist aber das ist eine
typische situation er ist nämlich der
adressen er ist täter er ist nicht opfer
und es ist sind auch nicht zwei parteien
wissen sie wenn es einen konflikt gebe
wo beide seiten wo man diskutieren
könnte wie löst man ihn auch weil beide
berechtigte anliegen haben das ist hier
nicht der fall deswegen ist diese
situation so wie sie sie beschreiben
aber das ist typisch für einen überfall
für einen angriffskrieg dass der
angreifer auch wenn die karten in der
hand hält und es ist etwas angetreten
und damit hat eingetreten damit hat
putin eben etwas getan was uns zu dieser
situation jetzt bringt womit wir aber
auch nicht gerechnet haben ist dieser
überfall auf die gesamte ukraine
ich will aber dazu ein strecken wenn wir
sagen wir haben damit nicht gerechnet
wir haben in deutschland vielleicht
nicht damit gerechnet aber wenn ich mit
kolleginnen kollegen östlich von uns
spreche dann sagen die mir es ist genau
das passiert
was wir euch immer gesagt haben und ihr
habt es runter gespielt ja business
gemacht ihr habt gesagt wenn die
wirtschaftsbeziehung stehen dann kann
das nicht passieren und jetzt sind wir
in der realität angekommen so sagen es
viele leute in warschau und den anderen
hauptstädten aber erzähl mir dann meinen
wir ja sie damit also ihre partei hat ja
die regierung gestellt in den letzten
jahren das nehmen sie dann so lässig zur
kenntnis und sagen ja die haben recht da
wir haben jetzt unsere fehler aufgedeckt
oder wie gehen sie damit um dass der
frontale kritik an der politik ihre
kanzlerin ihre regierung ihrer
verteidigungsminister ihrer ich will es
nicht sagen ihn an ihnen selbst aber
dass das beschreiben sie jetzt irgendwie
so als sei so ein historisches faktum
aber sie sind wir voll mit drin
also ich persönlich habe die sachen auch
wenn nicht so wie das gesagt wurde in er
im baltikum und auch in polen an um
starten so hart habe es nicht gesehen
aber natürlich ja clijsters kritikern
uns natürlich ist es kritik an uns all
die dass wir beispielsweise nicht unsere
verpflichtungen in der nato nach
gekommen sind das war fahrlässig aber
ich will an dieser stelle mal sagen
derjenige der das verhindert hat als
finanzminister ist heute bundeskanzler
gut dass er die kehrtwende gemacht hat
aber wenn sie jetzt fragen wer hat das
verhindert es war nicht die union es
waren die sozialdemokraten die jetzt die
kehrtwende zu recht einläuten wir haben
sie im wahlprogramm gefordert schauen
sie sich mal die aussagen von saskia
esken an in der sie der klipp und klar
gesagt hat die erklärung von annegret
kramp karrenbauer mehr für verteidigung
auszugeben das sei schockierend und das
würde es mit der spd nicht geben er hat
sie mir erklärten gestern hier in der
regie materie die cdu hat ein putin
problem und ich werde deswegen auch
direkt mal zu hause aber nachher
weiterleiten ist das so wie hat sie mir
das hier erklärt paul das ist nur die
spd ist also wenn eine partei an putin
probleme hat dann sich die spd mit
denjenigen die in aufsichtsräten und
vorständen russischer staatskonzerne
sitzen die das geld dafür zur verfügung
stehen die cdu hatte diese position aber
ich erhole mich nochmal ein jetzt müssen
wir die dinge mal trennen die gefahr
eines krieges eines angriffskrieges
eines überfalls durch russland haben
viele auch ich so in dieser form nicht
kommen sehen
paul wir geben zu dem du hast gerade
schon was sagen wollen das habe ich zu
spät gehört war es was mir sozusagen aus
der ukrainischen perspektive immer mehr
auffällt in den letzten tagen ist dass
ich das gefühl gehabt dass sowohl
beobachter als auch experten die ukraine
eigentlich aufgegeben haben wissen sie
gerade hinter mir hat es wieder geknallt
die explosion vor 15 minuten sie reden
und wir reden eigentlich schon darüber
hakan das irgendwie mit uns sind wir
damit drin dritter weltkrieg ja versteht
man ja jeder deutsche macht sich darüber
sorgen und natürlich ist dass die
haustür das wichtigste was vor der
haustür passiert aber momentan ist es
doch so dass wir die ukraine immer noch
völlig im stich lassen wir haben hier
zwar ein bisschen waffen her geliefert
aber die meisten waffen waren schrott
oder sind zu spät gekommen oder sind
nicht genug das sollten wir uns nicht
ernsthaft mal gedanken darüber machen ob
da momentan wirklich schnell genug alles
gemacht wird zum einen um waffen zu
liefern so viele wir haben so viele wir
haben um diese schreckens raketen
abzuschießen die putin jedem moment wo
ich gerade sitze hier auf diesen ort
schießen kann tun wir das erste und das
zweite ist tun denn ganz kurz das war
nicht an sie gerichtet es mir geht es
eher um die allgemeine debatte die wir
auch hier insgesamt in deutschland und
in europa führen und das zweite ist ich
glaube wir haben bei den sanktionen noch
längst nicht alles gemacht mir fehlt da
vor allem die persönliche komponente was
ist denn eigentlich mit putins geheimen
töchtern was ist denn mit putins
immobilien was ist denn mit den
angehörigen auf schulen universitäten
überall da hab ich noch nicht genügend
gehört darüber dass alles was westlich
ist für leute die den kreml direkt
unterstützen nicht mehr zugänglich sein
muss wir brauchen noch viel härtere
sanktionen
dezimiert wollen sie nach was endgegnern
sonst würde ich jetzt zu herrn strunz
weitergeben werden uns aber ich will ihn
klar widersprechen niemand hat weil ich
kann das für die union sagen die ukraine
auf geben ganz im gegenteil ist das im
januar noch in einer zdf talkshow mit
einem politiker der fdp da wurde das
argument vorgetragen na ja wir sollten
gar keine waffen liefern weil es bisher
kann ich möglich überhaupt die ukraine
zu verteidigen ihm habe ich vehement
widersprochen und genau das gefordert
was sie gerade gesagt haben zusammen
zwei dinge unterscheiden
hochkomplexe waffensysteme jetzt in die
ukraine zu liefern macht wenig sinn wenn
man daran lange menschen ausbilden muss
aber die alle waffen die jetzt sofort
eingesetzt werden können die sinn machen
ich bin dafür dass wir diese liefern